vite avec claude blanche maison qui est
expert en relations internationales
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
qu'est ce que la sphère pegasus révèle
sur le gouvernement marocain
je crois que ça s'appelle trois choses
la première c'est que bien entendu comme
on le sait les dirigeants marocains à
rabat sont très désireux de savoir ce
qu'on pense du maroc à paris et enjeux
du maroc en général et est peut-être
actuellement puisqu'il ya une crise du
sahara occidental en en particulier la
deuxième chose que ça que ça révèle
c'est que le maroc n'a pas les moyens
technologiques en propre pour mener ce
genre d'action les grands pays par
exemple les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité n'en parle pas mais
on ce genre de moyens en propre les pays
qui n'ont pas ce genre de moyens en
propre et c'est quelquefois de se
fournir sur le marché et c'est le cas du
maroc qui a acheté ce logiciel pegasus à
la firme israélienne qui le fabrique et
qui le vend avec une autorisation du
gouvernement israélien et plus
particulièrement des ministères de la
défense israélien donc ça fait aussi
partie de la diplomatie israélienne dans
le grand marchandage qui a eu lieu ces
derniers temps entre les etats-unis
israël et le maroc
monsieur tron part elle a reconnu que le
sahara occidental faisait partie du
maroc le maroc arrêtable a établi des
relations diplomatiques avec israël
mais le rapprochement était déjà en
cours depuis longtemps
la preuve puisque l'israël avait été
d'accord pour fournir ce logiciel marque
la troisième chose que ça révèle c'est
que au maroc comme ailleurs on confond
souvent lutte contre le terrorisme
espionnage politique
les israéliens lorsqu'on interroge
disent que ce logiciel est vendu avec un
mode d'emploi très strictes
très rigoureux c'est pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
évidemment tous les pays qu'ils achètent
ensuite en font ce qu'ils veulent et ce
qu'ils veulent c'est généralement lutter
contre le terrorisme mais aussi lutter
contre leurs ennemis politiques et
parfois aussi savoir ce que pensent
leurs meilleurs amis
c'est le cas du gouvernement marocain
alors bien sûr ce que j là c'est pas du
tout pour excuser les écoutes
c'est totalement inacceptable totalement
inadmissible des enquêtes sont en cours
et cela aura sans doute des conséquences
affaire d'espionnage que le consortium
de journalistes forbidden stories vie
aux intérêts du maroc au sahara
occidental est ce que cette affaire elle
marque
à votre avis nouvelle étape dans le
conflit qui oppose justement les
sahraouis au royaume chérifien
j'ai envie de vous répondre que j'ai
l'effet sur la sphère du sahara
occidental sera faible parce que la
sphère du sahara occidental
ces données sont bien connus il y à une
résolution des résolutions des nations
unies du conseil de sécurité des nations
unies qui en effet prévoit qu' il
faudrait que consulter les populations
sahraouies sur leur statut mais cela
fait tellement longtemps que ce problème
existe et d'ailleurs un héritage d'une
décolonisation un peu bâclé de la part
de l'espagne puisque c'était le sahara
espagnol qu'il a fallu attendre la
disparition de franco en 1975 pour que
les espagnols accepte de décoloniser est
immédiatement le maroc a dit que cette
partie du sahara lui appartenait
soulevant naturellement des
protestations notamment de l'algérie
mais aussi des sahwa alors les algériens
les
les algériens évidemment soutenu
systématiquement les sahraouis il ya eu
des combats et le maroc a construit un
mur
encore un un mur de 2700 km qui en fait
est le long de la ligne de cessez le feu
entre l'armée marocaine
les sahraouis appuyé par les algériens
80% du territoire et ce contrôle
marocain et le reste 20% sous contrôle
sahraouis mais entre les deux il ya un
mur et par conséquent cette situation
malheureusement risque de durer les
marocains veulent régler par des
négociations avec les sahraouis souhaite
que le nul ne s'en mêle pas trop or il
ya encore une fois ces résolutions et il
ya même des troupes qui observe la
situation sur place
des casques bleus les etats unis ont
pris le parti que monsieur trump a
choisi à savoir de dire le sahara
occidental c'est le maroc
joe biden est un peu revenu sur cette
position à 10 ans ce qui compte ce sont
les résolutions des nations unies c'est
aussi la position de l'union européenne
et par conséquent de la france alors
justement puisque vous parlez à de la
france claude blanche maison et cette
affaire à ce qu'elle peut nuire aux
relations diplomatiques entre le maroc
et ses partenaires la france 5 est un
partenaire du maroc la france dont
plusieurs journalistes personnalités
politiques ont donc été espionnée via le
logiciel pegasus ça va évidemment
provoqué un petit coup de froid ce qui
avec la chaleur de cette semaine dans le
fond sera peut-être une un gain domaine
mais toute plaisanterie mise à part
cette situation est très sérieuse il y
aura évidemment des protestations
française réveiller vigoureuse mais il
est probable que ça n'ira pas au delà
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
après wikileaks lorsqu'on a appris que
la nsa américaine et coûté à peu près
tout le monde
il ya eu des protestations c'est
scandaleux c'est inadmissible c'est
immoral mais on s'en est tenu là et
entre la france et le maroc les intérêts
qu'on les intérêts mutuels sont très
importants d'abord parce qu'il ya une
communauté marocaine en france une
communauté française au maroc
ensuite parce que les liens économiques
sont re traditionnellement très fort et
je pense que le refroidissement ne
durera que quelques temps le marque
d'ailleurs n'est pas le seul pays qui a
pratiqué ce genre de chose puisque
d'autres pays ont acheté le même
logiciel assez grand nombre la bulgarie
le kazakhstan l'inde est par conséquent
ces pays qui n'ont pas en eux par eux
mêmes leurs propres moyens
technologiques pour faire de
l'espionnage plus discrètement et bien
recours à ces moyens qui est
manifestement risque d'être découvert
par les enquêtes de la presse
internationale
merci à beaucoup avoue claude
blanchemaison pour toutes ces précisions
et analyse merci à vous